[Musique]
daniel local est situé sur le plateau du
moulon le sourcing des produits et le
projet en soi ont débuté en janvier 2020
et en neuf mois j'ai monté le projet
j'ai ouvert et références et du coût 80
fournisseurs nous avons accès de la
communication réellement sur les
produits locaux et du terroir
aujourd'hui on travaille avec un peu
plus de 80 fournisseurs présents
principalement d'eure-et-loir les
yvelines l'essonne paris la
seine-maritime ça regroupe un peu plus
de 500 produits 500 références
aujourd'hui le principe de la boutique
donc c'est des producteurs en circuit
court
donc c'est des circuits courts 10 soit
directement du producteur au
consommateur ou à l'occasion
intervenants donc tous les producteurs
présents sur la boutique sont des
personnes que j'ai contacté directement
que j'ai été voir et on est réellement
en circuit court
dieu de a à z sur sur tous les produits
j'ai été voir plus de 50 % des
producteurs directement alors leur
exploitation beaucoup sont des petits
producteurs qui sont en priorité avant
d'être commercial commerçants sont des
producteurs et artisans
on peut vous parler des produits vous
dire ah bah tiens intel à son usine qui
est neuf
intel a sa manière de fonctionner comme
ça parce qu'il ya un véritable échange
ale qui est des producteurs et artisans
les contraintes d'approvisionnement sont
du coup régulier est réglée par les
conditions climatiques par l'offre aussi
la demande qui assure sur le moment sur
certains produits
c'est réellement 500 plus de 500
produits qui sont disponibles et en
boutique et sur le site internet www.la
miam local point fr qui permet un drive
à partir de deux à quatre heures après
la commande pour venir récupérer
aujourd'hui ce qu'on peut nous souhaiter
c'est de développer la clientèle
je suis très présent sur les réseaux
sociaux que ce soit facebook instagram
linkedin sous le nom l'amiable locale
n'a besoin que les gens nous connaissent
pas de nous entendre parler nous pour
pouvoir parler de nous et n'hésite pas à
venir nous rencontrer dans la boutique
[Musique]